all right should we have a go
together um i just thought i'd warm your
brains up we've moved a little bit past
interquartile range um and quartiles as
a um
as a matter of focus because they're
okay as statistical tools but as you'll
see in this lesson like we've gone way
past interquartile range it's a fairly
quick tool that gives you a rough sense
but we we have more sophisticated um
tools in our arsenal to understand a
statistical data set however still very
handy it's like a quick and dirty look i
can just see this and get a sense of how
spread out a data set is that's what
interquartile range which is kind of the
end of the question is all about
now you've been asked i should unfreeze
this that would be helpful you've been
asked
to work out the middle quartiles q1 q2
q3 and hopefully like this is this is
why they started questions right um the
first thing that you needed to do with
these data sets is actually already been
done for you if you get given a data set
and you need to work out quartiles what
is the first thing you need to do with
that data before you can even work out
anything
yeah you need to get them in order which
you can see has already been handed to
you they're in ascending order you can
put them in descending order doesn't
matter does it but as long as you read
it the right way okay now i've
deliberately chosen these two because
before we look at the answers before you
guys give me suggestions
the key difference between these two
data sets
is not the actual data points but how
many data points there are make sense in
the first case there are
seven and in the other case there are
eight if i counted correctly and you
have to handle the quartiles slightly
differently in each case so let's have a
look at this one
first which is the easiest of the
quartiles to identify
just the meaning right because you're
looking right in the middle and in fact
q1 and q3 are in the middle of the two
sections you end up creating from the
median so because this is an odd number
of scores right uh one all the way
through to seven and they're in order
which of the scores what order along
from one to seven is the median
it's the fourth score right because it's
got three on either side so this one
right here that's going to be q
two the median
okay so then the next question is well
when i work out q1 the lower quartile
and q3 the upper quartile
which are the scores that i'm looking at
do i include 13 when i'm doing my
calculation here or not
you actually kind of exclude it right
you kind of then think about let's oopsy
does it let's
think of this as its own separate data
set and then we'll think of this as its
own separate data set and that makes it
actually quite straightforward doesn't
it that gives you q1 right there
and q3
right there you happy with how we
identified that so what is the
interquartile range in this case
it's just 10 17 take away seven happy
times all right so when we come over
here and we look at this data set
because you have an even number of
scores it's immediately different right
so
where do i look
i don't have a middle score anymore
there isn't uh like the fourth score and
the fit score neither of them is the
middle so what do i do
yeah i'm going to take the mean of the
two middle scores so that's these two
right here so i'm going to go
the median is equal to well it'll be 37
divided by 2 which i guess is
18 and a half happy that
okay so now i'm going to ask the same
question as i identify q1 and q3
where do i go which scores do i include
do i include 17 and 20
i do now hold on this is interesting to
me why do i include them this time but
before you told me to take it away i'll
answer that question in a second but
let's first actually do it so i'm going
to just draw a line right down the
middle okay and so this left data set
here we drew a box around it before
there's an even number of scores so when
i'm going for q1 what do i do
same thing that i did before right so
there's my 12 and 13. so that gives me
q1 being 12
and a half and then same exercise over
here
so the upper quartile is you've already
worked it out it's 20
25 and a half
okay and i'm not even going to work out
i don't know why i changed to um
fractions there i'll keep it decimals
i'm not even going to work out the
interquartile range because i think you
guys are fine with that okay now here's
the real question
why
did we include or rather sorry exclude
the median over here but you included
the two scores that created the median
over here
any suggestions ian what are you
thinking neither of them are actually
the actual meeting so the first
suggestion which is not a bad one by the
way is well i excluded the medium before
because it was one of the scores here
neither 17 or 20 are the median so i
just let them stay put i'm okay with
that's not a bad that's actually the way
that i learned it to begin with like
when i was in year 12. um but there's
actually a different reason that we can
go to for why we actually
include them
and not exclude them and i'll give you a
clue it's in the question richie what do
you reckon um because when we have from
the left for a 13 if we plan it for one
then we have to count to the other so be
almost double counting it but then for
the second one
okay all right so think about this for a
second say that again right if i
included it for here like 13 is in the
middle right
so therefore you sort of it's
overlapping between both of the um
scores as it were so you can't count it
twice when you're trying to add up like
i want a proportion that divides up my
score into four equal sections by the
way that one's the big clue over here
because 17 and 20 were not included you
can actually just go right down the
middle right now that's not bad again
it's in the right direction i think
there's an easier way to understand it
though which is that no one yet has said
so thumbs up to ian and richie for
putting their hat in danger do you want
it do you want to try more do you want
to carry the class because you've been
doing it
it's literally quarters so you've got
the median as the midpoint if it's one
side of the midpoint that's in one
corner it can't be in both quarters so
if you're not included if it's that
midpoint it can't be included in both
sides but it's easily in that midpoint
and it's in the quarter so it has to be
included
okay
i've got a question for all of you i
need an honest answer for this right
because it's feedback for for daniel and
for me as well i'm actually curious
who followed that explanation
oh one two three hands is it because you
were kind of thinking something similar
already or you're like no it made sense
okay so i followed it but mainly because
i already knew what the answer was right
and there's a lesson here for all of us
in terms of how we communicate our
working your working has to make sense
to someone who's not inside your brain
and hasn't already thought these
thoughts your thoughts before you have
right let me see if i can give the same
explanation but in a way that hopefully
will be we'll catch more of the class
okay
the core of it is exactly right a
quartile means and i know some of you
missed this but well actually let's all
write this down right wherever you've
got your question there
write down the word quartile again
because the key is in the word
a quartile is a score
that divides into quarters
it's a score
that divides
into quarters
and how many quarters
just
it depends on well which quartile are
you interested in right so the first
quartile there's one quartile
on the left the second quartile there's
two quartiles on the left the third
quartile there's three quartiles on the
left make sense okay now if that's the
case once you understand that once you
come over to this um
this set of eight scores it's very easy
to see why you have to
include the 17 and the 20. let's imagine
if we excluded them okay so let me um
i'm just i will need this working again
but i'm just going to put it over to the
side here okay let's just suppose we
included our 17 and our 20
in our calculation and then we said okay
i'm done with them now we kind of did
something similar to what we did before
okay and now i look at these two data
sets as separate and i look at their
medians as it were so if i then say ah
12
27
okay now think about what this means if
i say this
is a quartile
then to the left of it because this is
apparently q1 there should be one
quarter of the data what's to the left
of 12
it's just eight there's just a single
data point one out of eight that's not a
quarter of it that's an eighth of the
data twelve and a half percent make
sense whereas let's go back now if we
include those scores and now put this
back
okay 12 and a half that's what we're
saying
what's to the left of 12 and a half
answer two scores the eight and the
twelve that's a quarter that's the whole
point of a quartile that's what it does
make sense
so the reason why i'm highlighting that
is because we need to understand what
these things are doing and why and then
the process like whether you include it
or not you don't actually have to
remember like do i include it sometimes
do i not you just have to think about
the function that it serves okay
any other questions before we finish off
with starters can i ask now okay
how many of you understood that
explanation is it clicking for you now
now by the way don't forget daniel
because i've had like you know 15 years
of teaching this plus you know etc but
this is actually a really hard thing to
do to communicate to understand it first
and then to have that in a form that
others
can comprehend themselves